-Hi, Stacey. How are you?
-I am well. How are you, Seth?
-I'm doing very well.
We last spoke here
in the studio in February,
the night of
the New Hampshire primary.
Certainly, a lot
has changed since then.
-We still have
a country, though.
-Yeah. You know what?
It was a coin flip for a while,
but we still have a country.
And, certainly, one of the most
important things
to a country like this
is everyone's
free and fair right to vote.
You made a documentary about
voter suppression
over the years up to
and including
your gubernatorial election
in Georgia in 2018.
Was this something that
you ever saw yourself doing,
making a documentary?
-No, not at all.
I had actually been approached
by a few filmmakers
who were interested in doing
a documentary
about the 2018 election.
I was there.
I had no interest
in reliving it.
But it gave me the idea of
doing a documentary
that didn't focus on me
as a politician,
but really focused on the voters
and understanding the history
of voter suppression
so we could understand
its current impact
and we could mitigate
its future effect.
And, so, I actually
went shopping.
I found an amazing
producer/filmmaking partner
in Liz Garbus and Dan Cogan.
They brought on board
Lisa Cortés.
I got out of the way,
and they made this
extraordinary documentary.
And they tricked me into
being in it anyway.
But I think
they did a great job.
-One of the things the
documentary tries to lay out
is that what happened in 2018,
what's happening now --
this is not new.
A lot of it was
born out of Jim Crow.
Did you find that this
was something people
were educated about
or do you think
it was new to a lot of people?
-I think it's not only new,
but it's necessary reconnection.
In the sort of DNA of America,
we had to understand that
voter suppression was baked into
how our country was started.
But what really
cemented it for me
was a conversation with
one of my young staffers.
We were talking,
after the 2018 election,
about what had happened
and we were talking about
what was going on in Florida
with Desmond Meade
and his attempt to restore
voting rights
for ex-offenders
and returning citizens.
And she said, "Well, why do they
keep using the phrase
'poll tax'?
Isn't there a sexier way
to describe it?"
And it hit me
like a ton of bricks --
she had no idea that poll taxes
were legitimately taxes
that were imposed on others.
And the more we talked,
the more I remembered
I'm the daughter of
civil-rights activists.
If you're a Millennial,
if you are a Gen Z,
you've only ever lived with
the Voting Rights Act
being in place.
And you may have seen
"Eyes on the Prize" in class,
but you haven't really been
steeped in the story of
how hard it has been to,
first, expand the right to vote,
and now to defend it.
-You mentioned, obviously,
your parents helped connect you
to the history, but it seems
that you have always been
pretty connected to the history
up to and including --
You spoke at the
30th anniversary of
the March on Washington.
That is --
You're only 19 years old.
I imagine, at that age --
at any age --
there's a lot of pressure at a
speaking engagement like that.
How did it feel?
-I don't remember it.
I'm fairly certain
I blanked out.
That's a lot of people.
-Yeah.
-And, so, I remember getting out
of the car, going, you know,
through the process
getting up there,
and I looked out over
the Reflecting Pool
and saw all of those
thousands of people.
And then I remember being done.
My mom actually --
We talked that night.
This was before cellphones,
so I had to wait till
I got back to the hotel
and call her from a landline.
And she said, "How did it go?"
I'm like, "I don't know.
I don't remember.
I just remember there being
a lot of people there."
-Well, you know, trial by fire.
It's very important, obviously,
early on
to learn what it's like
being in front of
a group of people.
You know, obviously, a lot of
people are talking about
how this
election will be conducted,
the level of fairness involved.
It seems like the president
is doing a lot of work
to sow doubt about things
like mail-in voting,
obviously making it harder for
the Post Office to do their job.
Do you feel as though
people should be panicked
or do you think there's a way to
approach this in the coming,
you know, month and a half
to make sure
that we do have a fair election?
-We can do nothing about
the imposter in chief
that sits in The White House.
We can't control
what he says or what he does,
but we can control
our response and our power.
And, so, first, don't panic.
We know they're going to
keep doing things.
We know that he is going to try
his best to bully and cheat us
out of an election, but it can't
work if we do our part.
So, first, don't panic,
because when we panic, we miss
things and we make mistakes.
Number two, make a plan to vote
and make it early.
In 80% of the states
in our country,
you can vote by mail
with no excuses,
and you can start applying
for it now.
We have this amazing website
called allinforvoting.com.
It's a project that
we did through the film
and in partnership with Amazon.
It is an amazing set of
resources and tools.
You can do everything
from register,
to get your vote-by-mail
application,
to find out your early-voting
rules and your polling location.
So, plan to vote by mail.
If that doesn't work,
plan to vote early in person.
And if that doesn't work, have a
backup to your backup plan
and know where to go
and vote on Election Day.
So, one, don't panic.
Two, make a plan to vote early.
And, three, don't do it alone.
We need to make certain
that everyone
we know has a plan to vote,
that they tell you what it is.
Don't let them say, "Oh, yeah,
I'm going to make my plan."
Make them tell you what it is,
make them write it down,
because if we can
overwhelm the system
with our presence, we will win.
-You know, obviously, you had a
very close election in 2018.
You know, there is a chance that
maybe all of a sudden, you know,
Georgia is a swing state.
How are you feeling about
Vice President Biden's chances
as we're, you know,
40-some days out?
-I think he can win here.
We've got 16 electoral votes
we're willing to send his way.
We've got two Senate seats
that are up for grabs --
Jon Ossoff running against
David Perdue,
Raphael Warnock running against
Kelly Loeffler.
And with the right investment
and the right turnout,
we can pull both of those
Senate seats
over to the Democratic column.
We can also send
Lucy McBath back
and send her friend, in
Carolyn Bourdeaux, in the 7th.
And we can flip 16 House seats
and take the House
for Democrats.
These are all within reach,
because in 2018, without trying,
we flipped 16 seats
in the General Assembly.
We can do it again.
We're a narrow state.
It's a very close election.
And with the Secretary of State
controlling everything,
he barely eked out
a 55,000-vote victory.
We've had 750,000 new people
register to vote since 2018.
45% are under the age of 30.
49% are people of color.
And we've got really good
progressive white folks
in the state of Georgia
joining together.
And we have the ability
to win this election
and deliver Georgia
as a blue state.
-That's certainly
nice optimism to hear.
I do want to close.
I know you're busy.
I know you've got
a million things going on.
But as an accomplished author
and as someone I know
who loves TV and
films, what have you been doing
these last six months to unwind?
Anything good
we should know about?
-So, I just discovered a show,
"Body of Proof."
I really like crime dramas.
I just finished re-watching all
of "Elementary"
and discovered, because Hulu
recommended it for me,
"Body of Proof."
It's a pretty good show.
-Okay. Great.
-Alright, "Body of Proof."
That's all we're looking for is
recommendations
of, one, good crime shows,
and, two, how to save democracy,
and you always provide us both.
So good to see you, Stacey.
Always a pleasure.